Traduttore: Riccardo Fraccaro
Revisore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Qualcuno ha sentito parlare
di software open source o open design?
Alzate pure la mano.
Open design e uno dei suoi esempi,
software open source,
sono un'idea potentissima:
immaginate di andare a cena,
al ristorante o da un amico,
e immaginate che,
oltre alla pietanza che vi viene servita,
vi sia data anche la ricetta per farla.
Vi viene data
la lista degli ingredienti, tempi,
procedure, metodi per arrivare
al risultato finale.
Questa cosa sembra banale,
ma in realtà permette
di fare qualcosa di molto interessante:
potete guardare dentro la lista
degli ingredienti e provare a verificare
se c'è qualcosa a cui siete allergici,
potete farne delle varianti
(faccio la versione vegetariana
delle lasagne della nonna),
potete distribuire questa ricetta
agli amici a cui offrite la pietanza,
i quali, a loro volta, la lavoreranno,
faranno altre varianti.
Da cosa nasce cosa.
Qualcuno ha sentito parlare di Linux?
Alziamo sempre la mano.
Linux è probabilmente il risultato
più di successo del software open source.
Forse è quello più popolare,
forse è quello più noto,
è difficile misurare l'impatto,
però questo è un anno interessante:
Linux compie 25 anni, è nato nel '91
nella cameretta di un ragazzo,
(all'epoca ragazzo,
giovane uomo finlandese),
come un progetto
per passare il tempo,
dalla noia direi, collegandoci
al fantastico talk precedente.
In 25 anni, però, ne ha fatta di strada!
Perché dopo venticinque anni,
come dicevo, è forse la cosa,
come scala collaborativa
su livello globale,
più importante che abbiamo,
forse assieme a Wikipedia.
Parliamo di due cose diverse,
è solo per darvi l'idea,
magari avete più familiarità
con Wikipedia che con Linux.
Solo i numeri,
su cui non vogliamo fissarci,
vi danno un'idea del tasso di
progressione, di collaborazione,
che questo pezzo di software
(cos'è il software? è quella cosa che fa
funzionare i cellulari che avete in tasca,
il computer di Google
quando fate una richiesta,
il termostato di casa, fa funzionare
tutti questi pezzi di ferro
che chiamiamo computer, cellulare...)
Questo è alla base di molti
degli oggetti che usiamo quotidianamente.
Ma non è solo un hobby,
l'hobby del finlandese,
abbiamo delle organizzazioni
tra i primi dieci sviluppatori,
che dicono: "Sì, puntiamo a farla
questa cosa tutti assieme
e anzi, siamo tra i primi a crederci."
E non sono sicuramente delle no-profit
come queste che abbiamo sulla slide.
Pensate anche cosa succederebbe se si
fermassero, avrebbero problemi
a tenere l'infrastruttura
su tutta l'intera comunicazione,
e anche sempre più
quelle civili, cosiddette,
la rete elettrica e compagnia bella.
Tutto è partito dall'idea
di questo ragazzo che ha detto:
"condivido questa ricetta
per fare questo pezzo di software."
Ora, perché abbiamo parlato di Linux?
È un ottimo esempio dell'open design
instanziato nel software.
Open design non è solo
software open source,
è anche open hardware,
è anche open data.
Questo, però, è sempre un concetto
che ruota attorno al fatto di collaborare.
Ma torno un attimo indietro nel tempo.
Dieci anni fa, ero uno studente
in cerca di un argomento
per fare la tesi di laurea, qui a Padova,
e un professore aveva catturato
la mia attenzione con i robot
che dovevano entrare in scena
di lì a poco .
Erano stati degli avanzamenti
scientifici molto interessanti,
questi robot potevano finalmente,
almeno sulla carta,
percepire il mondo in cui si muovevano,
capire come generare traiettorie
per operare in questo mondo...
quindi, entusiasta,
iniziai a lavorarci qui
e poi un po' in giro per il mondo.
Il progresso, però,
era veramente lento.
Il risultato di una tesi di sei mesi,
di una tesi di dottorato di quattro anni,
era qualcosa che andava bene per
scriverci un articolo, mandarlo, però...
Qualcuno di voi ha familiarità
con i veicoli a guida autonoma?
Ne sentiamo parlare,
Tesla, qualcosa..., bene.
Questi sono degli ottimi esempi
su come la robotica
stia entrando nel nostro mondo.
Sono degli oggetti che percepiscono
l'ambiente intorno a sé
e decidono come muoversi.
Dieci anni fa, appunto,
quando stavo cercando l'argomento di tesi,
c'erano le prime competizioni della Drupal
nel deserto del Nevada,
c'erano questi veicoli
che grossi team di molte persone
provavano a ingegnerizzare e che forse
riuscivano, forse, in molte ore,
a concludere un giro sul circuito chiuso,
senza ostacoli, nel deserto.
Dopo dieci anni, quest'anno finalmente
mi tolgo la soddisfazione di farmi anch'io
un giro su questi veicoli
a guida autonoma, fantastici,
molto più precisi di un pilota umano,
devo dire.
Questi signori che mi spiegavano
come funzionava la cosa,
(nessuna mano sul volante, come vedete)
mi hanno anche spiegato
come fanno questo e non mi ha sorpreso.
Questa dell'open source è alla base
di molte innovazioni
tra cui quelle che stiamo vivendo
nel campo della robotica e,
ad esempio,
dei veicoli a guida autonoma.
Un'altra soddisfazione
che mi sono tolto quest'anno
è stata lunedì, quando il signore che
forse ora potremmo giudicare il padre
dell'incarnazione più moderna di Linux,
ci ha confermato: "Non ho ancora trovato
uno di questi veicoli che non sia basato
su questo pezzo open source."
Pensate alla cameretta del finlandese!
E pensate anche
che questo pezzo di software
fa andare tanto il cellulare, o il sistema
che usate in qualche server
per scrivervi su Whatsapp con gli amici,
quanto anche questi veicoli.
Ora il fatto che non sia una cosa banale
vi è indicato da dati come questi,
parliamo di società, di start-up,
che è un po' un termine in voga
per dire PMI di belle speranze
che in tre anni, con uno staff
di al massimo 40 persone,
come Cruise Automation in questo caso,
arrivino a sviluppare una tecnologia,
basandosi su questi strumenti,
che viene valutata un miliardo di dollari.
È un'acceleratore fondamentale, oppure
guardiamola dall'altro punto di vista:
quanto può fare una persona oggi
dotata di questi strumenti?
Una persona, come il signor George Hotz,
può fare il suo prototipo in casa,
attaccando alla sua Honda
un computer e una telecamera
e andando in giro
per le strade di San Francisco.
Non fatelo a casa!
Il giornalista che si è fatto un giro
ha avuto qualche momento interessante).
Però... una persona,
quando fino a pochi anni fa
ci volevano centinaia di tecnici
per avere un risultato molto inferiore.
Ora, torniamo un attimo indietro.
Open source si sta instanziando
nella robotica,
da molto vive negli altri
dispositivi che sappiamo,
e c'è un'altra onda che sta per arrivare
di cui parlano molto gli addetti ai lavori
ma di cui probabilmente sentirete parlare
se non ne avete già sentito parlare:
deep learning, intelligenza artificiale.
Questi grossi argomenti,
di cui si occupano
le società più grosse al mondo,
tra cui quelle che abbiamo visto prima
nella slide dei contributori di Linux,
lo fanno ma lo fanno
da subito in open source.
I signori di Google dicono:
"usate il nostro software,
contribuite, prendetelo",
mandano in giro delle persone
per spiegare come funziona,
per attirare la gente.
Hanno capito
che è il modello vincente.
E come i signori di Google,
ci sono i signori di Facebook,
ci sono anche i signori cinesi di Baidu,
cosa interessante perché finora
era un continente rimasto
un po' fuori da questo discorso.
Ma al di là di questo, facciamo
un altro passo indietro.
Abbiamo parlato di collaborazione,
abbiamo parlato di robotica,
di deep learning, tanti paroloni,
però pensiamoci un attimo:
c'è un'idea, secondo me sbagliata, che
è quella che l'età dell'informazione
sia nata con i computer (ingegneria
dell'informazione, età dell'informazione).
In realtà l'informazione nasce
con questa cosa che ho alle mie spalle,
che è uno dei primi esempi di scrittura.
Quindi nasce quando siamo passati
dalla preistoria alla storia,
con ciò che, convenzionalmente, viene
indicato come invenzione della scrittura.
Questo ha reso
l'informazione codificabile.
Un'idea potentissima che improvvisamente
ha permesso organizzazioni sociali,
ha permesso città, lo sviluppo
dell'agricoltura, del commercio,
che prima erano impensabili,
tanto da meritare un suo nome.
Lì è iniziata la storia!
Se andiamo avanti un po' di anni,
c'è un signore in Germania, nel 1440,
che si è inventato la macchina da stampa:
facciamoci una serie di bibbie intanto,
la Bibbia di Gutenberg.
Quello che sembrava solo
un cambio di qualità,
di fatto rese l'informazione
replicabile su larga scala.
Questa cosa ha un altro
impatto potentissimo.
Subito dopo, i vari Vesalio,
Copernico, i vari Newton, Galileo,
hanno potuto scambiare idee
con i colleghi su scala molto più grande,
hanno dato il via
alla rivoluzione scientifica
e quindi a quella industriale.
Per arrivare ai giorni nostri, però,
ci sono anche altre tappe.
All'inizio del secolo scorso, quando
lo sforzo bellico spesso è uno stimolo
per industriarsi, siamo arrivati,
con i vari signori Turing, Von Neumann,
ad avere informazioni in forma eseguibile,
quindi pensate ad ogni tassello
che andiamo ad aggiungere
a questa pila di qualità
che stiamo dando all'informazione.
Se facciamo un "avanti veloce"
ai nostri giorni,
qualcuno riconosce questo?
È il primo server web,
installato da Tim Berners Lee
al CERN di Ginevra nel 1989-90,
e questo, inizialmente, sembrava solo
un modo un po' più furbo
di usare una rete che già esisteva
che era internet o arpanet.
In realtà, questo è stato
il quarto salto di qualità,
e per questo secondo me
si può parlare di storia 4.0,
perché ha reso l'informazione
generabile collettivamente
mettendo a disposizione
gli strumenti per farlo.
Questo è alla base di tutti i vari
strumenti di sviluppo.
Se siete uno sviluppatore software,
conoscete github.
Anche semplicemente il fatto di potersi
scambiare messaggi via email
con sviluppatori di tutto il mondo
ha reso possibile Linux,
che, guarda caso,
è partito nel '91.
Vi faccio anche notare un'altra cosa:
questi passaggi sono avvenuti
su una scala temporale che è andata
via via assottigliandosi.
Siamo passati da migliaia di anni,
a centinaia di anni, a decine di anni.
Forse chissà, ci troveremo
di nuovo tra qualche anno
e parleremo di un ulteriore passaggio?
Grazie.
(Applausi)